[ZH] 對不起,我翻譯了
[ZH] 那這邊提問的問題是給Berry回答的
[ZH] 第一個是學校教育端來說的話
[ZH] 是怎麼樣可以幫助學生是已經有心理障礙
[ZH] 或是說甚至有自殺意念要怎麼幫助他們
[ZH] 那第二個是我們講到就是Lifeskills Coach這個概念
[ZH] 那社會或是社群是可以如何扮演這個角色
[ZH] 第一次問是教育學生,如何能夠準備好學生,或是有所謂的想法。
[EN]  at school like teachers how to be prepared to help students who are mentally
[EN]  disabled that's a great question first of all I want to say it's hard work to
[EN]  be an educator and to have a classroom full of 30 or 40 students and at the
[EN]  same time pay attention to the one one who's challenged is extremely difficult
[EN]  Because your priority is to teach and educate, to manage behavior takes all of your resources and sometimes it eclipses teaching.
[EN*]  I believe that it is a challenge for teachers.
[EN*]  There are three or four students who have to put in some of the children's minds.
[EN*]  However, there is a saying that I grew up with in the UK, an ounce of prevention is better than a pound of cure.
[EN*]  So, I do believe there are things you can do in the classroom to help things go right.
[EN*]  And I want to break down just two simple skills that are simple to do, but you have to be intentional with them.
[ZH] and if you do them, it can change the outcome.
[ZH] 那我相信就是,你剛才講防範盛治療,就是我相信可以在教室裡面做出一些事情來確保的是,
[ZH] 不是確保,就是讓可能事情會有比較好的發展,那這邊有兩個技能.
[ZH] 第一個技能叫做預測
[ZH] 比如說我現在有30個學生的班,然後有兩個同學比較不守秩序
[ZH] 在我開始教課前,我可能就會把這兩位同學先帶到旁邊去,做出一些相應的措施。
[EN*]  I would do it in a warm, relational way.
[EN*]  I would set a goal.
[EN*]  And then at the end of the classroom period,
[EN*]  I would give both students brief feedback.
[EN*]  And after this lecture, I'll give them a chance to get back to the second.
[EN*]  You have to recognize the positive gains that a student makes.
[EN]  Even if they're so small, you have to recognize the positive.
[EN]  So for every piece of constructive feedback you gave a student, you'd want to give him at least two positives.
[EN]  So he feels like he is making a difference.
[EN]  And once that student has received positive feedback, it will help him gain momentum.
[EN]  Now sometimes you have to search for the feedback, sometimes you have to look really hard.
[EN]  But what you're going to see is that as you focus on the positive, you're going to reinforce it and see more of it.
[ZH] 我想其實我剛聽到的是正向教養的力量
[ZH] 就是試著在給他們的回饋當中
[ZH] 我至少有兩個點是正向的
[ZH] 雖然有時候對老師來說有點難找到
[ZH] 但是還知道努力的找
[ZH] 因為他們有了正向的回饋
[ZH] 其實就會更有動力的去把事情做好
[EN*]  Forecasting and looking for the positive
[EN*]  doesn't guarantee an outcome,
[EN*]  but over time, if you're intentional,
[EN*]  It will move the needle in the right direction.
[EN*]  Would you like me to answer the second question?
[EN*]  The second question is how society or communities play a role in this kind of life-scale culture concept?
[EN*]  This is where it is really challenging.
[EN*]  I just spoke with Tiffany a moment ago after I gave my lecture.
[EN*]  Her son is on the spectrum and has ADHD and has struggled with basic responsibilities in life.
[ZH] 我們都知道現實生活中其實是很殘忍的,就是通常沒有辦法完全接納這樣的孩子。
[ZH] 但是身為大型的機構我們還是需要去接納他們的,但是我講到大型機構可能只佔在這個世界的百分之二十了。
[ZH] 八百分之二十就是可以靠的機構努力
[ZH] 那80%的話,就是Tiffany的孩子他可能會需要接受每週四到五次的治療
[ZH] 但是現實層面來講的話,其實這些治療計劃是很貴的
[ZH] One of the realities in the United States is that the private sector drives the medical world, but it is different everywhere else
[ZH] 在美國的話,大部分有需求的孩子會求助於私人機構,
[ZH] 就是私人機構比較像是在處理這一塊
[ZH] 在美國的話大部分是這樣的狀況
[ZH] 不是,它的意思是
[ZH] 他們這一些費用是從私人醫療
[ZH] 所以你自己要在美國要買私人醫療關係
[ZH] 那私人的醫療關係不負責
[ZH] 因為剛剛有講的醫療關係
[ZH] 相信國業之外
[ZH] 它是私人醫療機構
[ZH] 因為人自己要買保險
[ZH] 但我已經像我們也沒有人的名字
[ZH] 就是你自己買保險
[ZH] 然後保險後的名字
[ZH] I grew up in the UK
[ZH] where the medical world is dominated by the public sector
[ZH] Barry他是在英國長大的
[ZH] 那在英國的情況下
[ZH] 大部分的醫療機構的話
[ZH] 大家都會去比較公立的醫院
[ZH] 那在美國的話,確實大部分的醫療支出是要帶大家去私人的醫院做診療。
[ZH] The truth is, one is not significantly better than the other, both have positives and both have negatives.
[ZH] However, what the private sector can give is competition.
[ZH] 那有了競爭的話,其實機構就會互相去獨立,然後去進步,還有創新
[ZH] 下一個問題是給Drew, 接下來是給Drew, 如何幫助一個 ADHD 孩子遇到遇到他經常被被殺掉,像同學和家人,當他遇到他們的經濟和教授和教授,和不合理的理論,而使用自己的自信心,自信心的行為,或是保護他的心心,從重複裂的經濟。
[ZH] 如果當一個患有過動症的孩子,他的想法好像天馬行空,然後邏輯不連貫,然後他會忍不住打斷對話,或是打斷老師的話
[ZH] 那因為這樣子總是感覺被同學或是家人打壓制止,然後進而他就會開始自我貶低,擺爛,自我毀滅,來保護他脆弱受創的內心,要怎麼樣協助他應對
[ZH] 對,我覺得ADHD還常會面臨這樣的困境,因為他們跟別人比較難產生連結,
[ZH] 其實不管是老師還是臨床妹人看都會覺得還蠻危險的。
[ZH] It sounds like there's some other symptoms that go along with that, such as social struggling as well.
[ZH] And so you need to focus on different things, whether it's the ADHD, helping him calm down, find different things to do,
[ZH] to manage his time, but also to fidget, maybe give him some fidget spinners, also deep breathe.
[ZH] He needs to learn some skills to work through that.
[ZH] Mindfulness is a really good one as well.
[ZH] When it comes to social struggles, though, you teach him things like timing, tact, and tone,
[ZH] 那就是ADHD的孩子,我們就是必須要教他們許多的技巧,比如說如果冷靜,如果找到其他原因的事情去做
[ZH] 還有幫助他們如何建立健康的關係
[ZH] 因為像ADHD很多是男孩子,他們在關係上面會衝太快了
[ZH] 那就是要幫助他們建立這方面的關係
[ZH] 就是幫助他們如何建立比較健康的關係
[ZH] 因為像EDHD很多是男孩子的時候
[ZH] 他們在關係上面會衝太快了
[ZH] 那就是要幫助他們建立這方面的技巧
[ZH] 這一是要補充嗎
[ZH] 因為我覺得我有一段很像漏反了
[ZH] 好那第三個問題是給林主任的
[ZH] 就是請問ASD和BPD的差異
[ZH] 然後如何區分兩者在社交上面的表現
[ZH] 然後勤聴生的家長想要提問我
[ZH] 究竟要不要讓我的孩子用藥
[ZH] 因為他用藥後看起來會呆呆的
[ZH] 那個BPD是指變遺性人格嗎?
[ZH] 變遺性人格障礙
[ZH] 有些高分子的自閉症
[ZH] 就是他們還是有社交需求
[ZH] 想要對人家建立關係
[ZH] 但是他們在人的覺察上面
[ZH] 確實是比較困難的
[ZH] 所以有些變成會是高焦慮
[ZH] 就是他們在別人的一些反應
[ZH] 然後跟別人的一些對他的一些行為
[ZH] 他會過度詮釋
[ZH] 那常常也會因為就是會擔心自己會被拋棄
[ZH] 或是說就因為他們交朋友困難
[ZH] 所以他們會很抓住他們手邊的這個朋友
[ZH] 所以就會極盡的討好
[ZH] 然後會甚至有些會獨佔
[ZH] 他會擔心說他去找別人玩
[ZH] 因為他就擔心這個朋友
[ZH] 別人比較有吸引力就把他朋友吸走了這樣
[ZH] 因此他們有時候就是蠻患得患失的
[ZH] 因為不確定對方的狀態
[ZH] 因為他們的心智力會比較弱
[ZH] 他們去判對別人的意圖
[ZH] 別人的情緒能力比較弱
[ZH] 所以他們常會用一些測試的方法
[ZH] 想要去測試說你到底有沒有關心我
[ZH] 那這個行為就很像邊緣性人格
[ZH] 邊緣性人格他的診斷準則是指說
[ZH] 他的一個自我認同
[ZH] 還有人際關係的不穩定
[ZH] 那自閉症的小朋友
[ZH] 他比較核心是在他社交覺察上的困擾
[ZH] 所以我們通常可能還是
[ZH] 就是到後來可能兩個人的行為表現會有點像
[ZH] 那有些自閉症的小孩
[ZH] 他甚至會有一些自殺行為
[ZH] 然後就是因為自閉症本來就會全有全無
[ZH] 他們本來就是被那幾百
[ZH] 他們就是完美不然我就是失敗
[ZH] 他們在想事情是這樣
[ZH] 所以這個部分也跟別人性人格很像
[ZH] 所以這個診斷上可能會需要去了解說
[ZH] 她的情緒覺察能力是不是有一些困擾
[ZH] 然後她的心智理論
[ZH] 或是她就是有沒有辦法去判斷別人的意圖
[ZH] 或是別人做這些事情
[ZH] 背後的這個情緒或意義這樣
[ZH] 或是她自己的情感連結
[ZH] 她有沒有辦法做好
[ZH] 因為很多致病症的小孩
[ZH] 甚至連自己的情緒
[ZH] 為什麼會這樣發生
[ZH] 他們都不太能夠正確的連結
[ZH] 所以這個部分就是要去確認
[ZH] 她這個部分有沒有困難
[ZH] 那致病症的診斷還有第二大項
[ZH] 他需要有一個就是通常行為
[ZH] 我們說RBI,侷限興趣與通常行為這樣
[ZH] 那比較困難的是女生
[ZH] 常常他們的侷限興趣都不是太特別
[ZH] 常常喜歡的是追星,然後喜歡動漫
[ZH] 所以很多就會看很多漫畫
[ZH] 然後喜歡畫畫,畫很多動漫的東西這樣子
[ZH] 那或是聽音樂
[ZH] 那這個東西你就覺得跟一般新少年也很像
[ZH] 所以有時候這個部分我們不太容易覺察到
[ZH] 那可能就是另外一個就是思考的部著性
[ZH] 它可能不是在他們的routine上面
[ZH] 我一定要有一個SOP
[ZH] 比較是他們觀念一旦形成
[ZH] 你就很難去撼動它
[ZH] 它很難被說服這樣子
[ZH] 那再來就是說他們可能會有一些高敏感
[ZH] 現在坊間講的高敏感
[ZH] 其實我覺得一大部分會有一點ASD的trade
[ZH] 所以我們只要整天聽到高敏感這件事情
[ZH] 我們大概就會開始去survay
[ZH] 看有沒有其他AS相關的症狀
[ZH] 就是對別人的情緒共感性特別的強
[ZH] 尤其是負面訊息
[ZH] 他可能會看到
[ZH] 就是老師可能在很兇很大聲
[ZH] 他在罵別人
[ZH] 但是他就會開始感到害怕
[ZH] 因為他會擔心他哪一天被罵這樣
[ZH] 然後可能看戲劇啊
[ZH] 別人在哭啊很危險
[ZH] 他就緊張到完全都不敢看
[ZH] 甚至在那邊大哭這樣
[ZH] 變成是他是
[ZH] 不是那種人家概念中
[ZH] 那種好像對別人情緒完全無感
[ZH] 他本來是overshooting
[ZH] 就是過度的敏感這樣
[ZH] 然後另外就是觸覺敏感
[ZH] 聽覺敏感是大家知道的東西
[ZH] 所以我們也會去看這些東西說
[ZH] 他有沒有這些特質去做一點鑑別診斷
[ZH] 有可能到後來一個自閉症的小孩
[ZH] 他的確會發展出別人性人格沒有錯
[ZH] 如果就是就現象學來上看會是這個樣子
[ZH] 用藥的問題
[ZH] 剛才說要不要讓他…
[ZH] 情緒障礙
[ZH] 情緒障礙用藥就是我不知道指的是哪種
[ZH] 如果是ADHD的藥就是我們會用力它
[ZH] 那這個樣子就是它在濃度太高的時候
[ZH] 它的確會看起來就是會有點變慢
[ZH] 然後有點呆滯這樣子
[ZH] 那這個東西可以靠調整藥物的劑量
[ZH] 必須可以做一點點就是改善
[ZH] 因為它跟濃度是有相關性的
[ZH] 就是其實它是興奮劑嘛
[ZH] 那我不知道大家有沒有聽過一個興奮劑
[ZH] 像安貝塔幣他們在用的時候
[ZH] 它會執著,它就是看了一個點
[ZH] 然後看了看,看了很久都不會轉移
[ZH] 它反而變成它的attention shifting
[ZH] 就是助力轉移會有問題這樣子
[ZH] 所以這個是可以靠藥物調整做改善
[ZH] 那如果你說的是另外一種是多巴胺調節劑
[ZH] 像現在很常見的是
[ZH] 迪斯密陀、羅雅達、逆腐這類的藥
[ZH] 那它確實因為它有一些鎮定的效果啦
[ZH] 所以小朋友有時候吃完會覺得頓頓的這樣子
[ZH] 那也是可以跟醫生討論藥物的
[ZH] 置換或是劑量的調整
[ZH] 就是看一看
[ZH] 那當然我預計說有些小孩就是真的很敏感
[ZH] 他吃什麼藥都會有副作用
[ZH] 就很難調整這樣
[ZH] 那有時候真的就是也沒辦法吃藥
[ZH] 所以也是需要老師跟家長
[ZH] 多多就是利用開口的一些技巧
[ZH] 那我覺得老師跟家長
[ZH] 自己也蠻需要別人的支援
[ZH] 很多時候可能自己都需要去找心理治療
[ZH] 來去處理自己就是一些挫折跟困擾
[ZH] 對
[ZH] 謝謝
[ZH] 那我們最後一點是給曾主任的
[ZH] 請問神經多樣性供照中心
[ZH] 只服務學齡級的物件嗎?
[ZH] 以及公造中心學員的資格條件僅限於特殊生嗎?
[ZH] 因為有一些小朋友他是做過評估
[ZH] 但結果是領界,是歸納正常的
[ZH] 是否也能有相關的支援系統?
[ZH] 亞洲人、額少、曾經都會是公造中心
[ZH] 是一個示範中心
[ZH] 剛好這個是近年度以後
[ZH] 能夠衛生局支援下我們成立
[ZH] 成立以後,這個是個Modal
[ZH] 我們也希望在這收的量不是很大
[ZH] 我們希望不同層次的小孩都會進來
[ZH] 假如說六歲以前的話
[ZH] 兒少女院就直接進去了
[ZH] 然後跟程度不嚴重
[ZH] 分程度我們都會進入做關懷
[ZH] 我們在國外來講
[ZH] 可能有某程度以上才會有個管
[ZH] 然後只要進入了就不用了
[ZH] 但我們現在在模特兒的話
[ZH] 可能會不同程度也會讓我們進入關懷
[ZH] 不同的需求
[ZH] 所以比較嚴重大會的個案比較少
[ZH] 所以我們固定了Case Manager、個案管理師
[ZH] 去做個管
[ZH] 以及家庭、小孩、父母的部分
[ZH] 所以整個模特兒在進行
[ZH] 企業分子在開始啟動
[ZH] 然後零九中、傅子雯
[ZH] 我們共同在為新北市
[ZH] 先創入一個新的模特兒在進行
[ZH] 另外提到Live Culture的部分
[ZH] 生活導師還有底目等都要說他怎麼位階
[ZH] 其實在國外來講
[ZH] 我們也是在國外學習到
[ZH] 國外人很難找到精神科醫師
[ZH] 以及心理治療師
[ZH] 所以往往來講
[ZH] 在過程當中需要一個陪跑友
[ZH] 就是來個學校 coach
[ZH] 來解決他生物上的問題
[ZH] 包括生物技巧部分
[ZH] 所以這個模特兒很好
[ZH] 就像我們在帶進臺灣
[ZH] 我們跟社會局合作
[ZH] 做訓練計畫也是一樣
[ZH] 我們希望大家來訓練
[ZH] 那群人可能是家長、老師、社工、志工都可以收訓
[ZH] 收訓以後,他可以有辦法去陪伴一些小孩
[ZH] 然後進少年,然後度過一些時間
[ZH] 據統計大部分來講,他要度過18歲到24歲
[ZH] 然後他承認完以後,慢慢就可以自己照顧自己
[ZH] 所以Live Coach 只是一個中間協助的部分
[ZH] 有沒有Pay們不知道
[ZH] 似乎去提到說這樣的訓練完之後
[ZH] 他可能會給一個小時多少錢
[ZH] 能讓那個Sed Life Coach
[ZH] 可以去幫助這群的介紹人和小孩童
[ZH] 所以是這樣來做下去的一個想法
[ZH] 好謝謝
[ZH] 早上的演講跟總統討論到這邊
[ZH] 我相信有一些題目在大家心裡面更清楚了
[ZH] 但是也有一些題目因為學習更多知識又更困擾了